this Christmas it's okay that we're here  it's okay that you're here did she do  that to us  [Music]  Star Wars the rise of Skywalker this  film is not yet rated confronting fear  it's the destiny of a Jedi your destiny  [Music]  if this mission fails it was all for  nothing  [Music]  we're not alone good people will fight  if we leave them  got you yes it's here  starwars arise of Skywalker tickets  available now oh we've done all this  time we're doing there are three bill  taking one last look sir but my friend  [Music]  confronting fear  is the destiny of the Jedi  your destiny  we're all in this  command star wars the rise of Skywalker  I think it's available now  [Music]  confronting fear  is the destiny of a Jedi your destiny  [Music]  the force will be with you always  [Applause]  and tickets available now  you